you know unfortunately it wouldn't be a
christmas special in 2020
without the following segment take a
look
it's time for a q a news break
america this christmas it's time to wake
up and learn the identity of the biggest
deep state criminal of them all
santa claus born saint nick in 270 a.d
santa has survived to this day by
feasting on the plasma of millions of
children
his bright red cheeks proof of his
insatiable lust
how does he get away with it because for
years santa has been propped up by the
hollywood pedo industrial complex
where he's been featured in over 100
films all glorifying his maniacal
invasion of youngsters homes to harvest
their blood
yes hollywood where santa is sheltered
thanks to his carefully cultivated
relationship with power broker brook
shields and coddled by the warm embrace
of the mainstream news media
santa is here no wonder he's able to
move freely among the deep state's
greatest felons
and now meet santa's boss shown for the
first time in this deleted scene from a
children's classic
where rudolph surveys his kingdom and
santa is broken and brought to heal by
the evil reindeer and his eight demon
disciples
yes rudolph who keeps santa on a short
leash
as he in turn administers to his deep
state minions
melania tried to warn us with her santa
hat trees
but we wouldn't listen so now it's time
for all of us to wake up
before it's too late next time on q a
news break learn how jesus christ
a confirmed bachelor and known jew
who is beloved by hollywood and
confessed to spending 40 days at a
desert retreat with the devil
might just be the biggest deep state
double agent of them all
this has been the q anon news break
man that makes you think doesn't it andy
yeah i think that my great aunt was
right